You aren't very far along, but
you have that sense of confidence.
I can do this language.
Hi there, Steve Kaufmann, and
today I wanna talk about how do
you get started in a language.
Uh, remember, if you enjoy
these videos, please subscribe.
Click on the bell for notifications,
uh, so you'll know when a
new video has been published.
And if you follow me on a podcast
service, please leave a comment.
So I often get asked the question like,
how do you get started in the language?
And you know, here I am, you know, 77.
In the last 17 years I've
learned 10 languages.
So I have started a lot of languages.
And of course we say that the key to
language learning is comprehensible input.
But when you start in a language,
nothing is comprehensible.
So then how do we get a
toehold in the language?
So I, I would like to share with you
uh, sort of my experience and, and even
with languages that I've learned in the
last, say, 15 years or so, which have,
you know, different writing systems
like, uh, Greek or, uh, Ukrainian
or Arabic or, uh, you know, Korean
or uh, Persian and stuff like that.
Very difficult.
Particularly if the writing system is,
is is different from what you're used to.
You know, the Latin alphabet
that we spent, our whole lives,
uh, reading in where it's, it's
basically second nature for us.
So how do you get started?
So, a few concepts.
First of all, believe you're
gonna get there, okay?
It seems almost impossible.
It's like looking at a, you've got a, a
jigsaw puzzle and there's nothing there.
There you've got a bunch of little
tiles, funny shapes, and, and
yet, you know there's a picture.
You know, there's a picture there.
And, and, and you know, from experience,
if you've handled jigsaw puzzles
before that gradually as you put more
and more pieces on the table, you're
gonna see how they connect together.
And over time, uh, you're
gonna get a full picture.
But when you start out,
it seems impossible.
But it's, it's, it's very, you know,
important to have that feeling that
in time, with enough time and if I
remain motivated then I will get there.
Okay.
Because at first it seems impossible,
particularly when I had to try to
learn the Arabic writing system.
I, I don't remember 50 years ago
when I learned Chinese, but for, um,
Arabic and Persian, I had to decipher
this, this writing system where the
characters very, you know, depending
on whether it's the beginning of a, of
a word, the middle of the word, or the
end of the word, like there's lots of
complication, but you have to believe.
The next thing is repetition.
You know, as, as I often quote Manfred
Spitzer who said, You know, uh, to learn
things, we need two things: we need
repetition, and we, we need novelty.
Okay?
The language is new, but
it's incomprehensible.
So there's not that rewarding
kind of novelty because you
don't understand what's there.
So you need repetition.
You need to get the neurons to fire.
So you have to do a lot of repetitive
reading and listening lots.
Uh, I often mention that I
start with the mini stories.
Even though I'm, in a way, it's, this
is, it's not like, Hello, how are you?
My name is, How old are you?
Not that kind of stuff.
It's actually relatively simple
stories where there's a lot of
repetition within each story.
Most vocabulary repeats five times in a
different tense or a different person.
Uh, and so I go through, typically in
sentence mode in LingQ, and I look up
the words and I listen to the wor...
the sentence, and then I eventually
get through that whole lesson,
five minutes worth of a lesson.
I listen to it again.
I don't wait.
And I think this is another point, I
don't wait till I fully understand it,
because I'm not going to understand it.
When you're starting into it, even if
you go through it and you look up every
word and you went through the sentence
and you'd think you know what the
sentence means, but when you hear it
again, you say, I can't understand it.
So the idea that you're gonna
ace lesson one before you move
to lesson two is not a good idea.
I typically, as I say, I use the
mini stories I go lesson one.
I get a bit of a sense of it.
Now.
This desire for novelty takes over even
though I don't understand lesson one.
I wanna go to lesson two
becasue I'm tired of, you know,
uh, beating my head against a
brick wall with lesson one and not
understanding, so I go to lesson two.
New stuff.
New story.
Okay.
I have the translation there.
I can look up words.
I'm kind of listening to
it, and you just keep going.
And then at some point you
go back to lesson one again.
And on that basis, typically I'll notice
that in my statistics at LingQ, I will
listen to particularly the first 10 or
15 stories - we have 60 mini stories.
I'll listen to them 30 or 40
times  but not at one sitting.
It's very important to not push yourself
too hard to try to learn this now.
You have to recognize that the
brain doesn't learn that way.
The learn the brain wants
the novelty, wants to mean or
wants to go onto new things.
And then you can come back to it later on.
Don't, you know, try to ace things.
And another advice I would
have is listen before reading.
And the reason for that is when
you listen, of course you don't
understand but you've now got
a certain degree of curiosity.
Like, what was that?
And, and this is true at the
beginning when it's all just noise.
But even later on as you progress in the
language, you start to hear where words
end and begin, even though you don't know
those words, you get a, you know, as the
jigsaw puzzle starts to fill out, you
get a better sense of the words there.
And so you start to become, you know,
curious and curious is a tr curiosity is a
tremendous driver, a tremendous motivator.
So by listening first you, you increase
your level of curiosity in that text,
you've also got a bit of momentum so that
when you go to read, and particularly
if you're reading, you know, in sentence
mode and you listen to that sentence,
you can hear the audio for that
sentence and you've heard it before.
All of that is building up some
momentum because when you are reading,
you're gonna be sub-vocalizing.
You have to...
the, the whatever you're reading
represents the sound, so you
have to have a sense of what that
sound is, or at least some of it.
So I very much recommend listening
even though you don't understand.
But then getting right in there to try
and save words, to get some sense of what
it's about, and then you listen again
and it's this repetitive activity of, of
listening and reading, uh, and going over
the same material over and over again.
That's gonna be a big part of,
I would say the first three
months of your language learning.
Uh, the first three months,
uh, is somewhat satisfying.
It doesn't matter what you can say,
day one, you know "my name is...".
That doesn't really matter.
What matters is are you
starting to understand more.
Is your brain start...
brain starting to get
used to the language?
And the first three months, if you
do a lot of repetitive listening, I
find that I have a lot of tolerance
for repetitive listening and reading
in the early stage in the language,
because the language is so new to me.
So I am combining that repetitive,
repetitive, you know, the repetition
with the sense that the language is new.
So there's some novelty there.
I'm curious.
I want to get to know the language better.
How does the language work?
And so that drives me through
that first three month period.
And, and that is a, if you can get
to where you have a feeling that
you made significant progress in
the first three months, it's not
that you understand everything.
Lots of the, what you listen
to, you don't understand.
You keep forgetting the words.
You can't really say much.
You aren't very far along, but
you have that sense of confidence.
I can do this language, and that...
That's where the first
three months are so crucial.
You have to push yourself in
that first three months to
get to where, you know what?
I knew nothing about the language
when I started and now look at me.
I can actually understand some
things, and that is, in my
experience, tremendously motivating.
Now you can start crawling out from
that and exploring other things.
I should also point out that I
generally like to buy a starter book
to go with my, uh, activity at LingQ.
So it can be a Teach Yourself, it can be
a colloquial, there's a, and and if your
native language is not English, I'm sure
there are starter books from whatev...
for whatever language you're trying
to learn based on your language.
It gives you an overview of the grammar.
Yes, you can also Google and download
grammars, but there's something to holding
onto a book, flipping through a book.
You sit down in a chair, you're looking
through a book, it's very useful to
have that companion starter book, and
it's something you look back to with
nostalgia when a year or two later
you're quite good in the language.
It's nice to look back at that
starter book that got you started,
um, and it sits on your shelf.
And even though I don't need
it anymore, I keep it there.
So that's some advice.
It's not the whole story.
It's some advice on how to
get started in a language.
And I look forward to your questions.
Thank you for listening.
Bye for now.